[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's
host of the Dr John deloney podcast
which is so popular and his brand new
book just hit number one last couple
months ago here building a non no
building a non anous life number one
bestseller again twice over so we're
answering your questions today about
your life your money your relationships
the phone number is8
825-5222 want to start with the fact
that you're one of my heroes so this is
one of the coolest moments right now for
me to be able to talk to you and so I
appreciate you taking my call I'm
honored how can we help um so a credit
card is suing me um paying some of my
stupid tax apparently um so it popped up
out of nowhere it's um and I I already
answered the summons and I'm trying to
figure out where to go from
here okay uh how much do you owe them um
8,100 wow okay is that the actual
balance or the puffed up balance after
they added a bunch of fees to it the
puffed up balance what was the actual
balance um I believe it was uh
7,400
7,500 um so a little bit of background
on this the reason I don't know the
exact numbers is it was actually um my
abusive X that opened up the card in my
name and um I never used a card myself
and um I had to run away from that
relationship with my kids and I forgot
about the card and I'm sorry you knew
about the card but you didn't sign for
it
correct okay how long ago was
that um
2019 okay how old are you um I am 29
what do you
make um so I run an inhome hair salon
and I make about um $1,300 a month um
plus I have um child support of how much
um 1,500 and that's from the abusive X
um no that is from my ex-husband not the
abusive
ex
um a debatable but that's not I'm talk
it's not the one you ran from the that
opened the credit card correct okay
that's what I'm trying to get get
straight all right you have any
money um so I have about $1,500 in
savings currently who's who's suing you
what company is this what what what
credit card company JP Morgan Chase yeah
okay all
right and you have an actual summons to
go to court an actual the sheriff
brought it to your door correct well I
was um served by a person not a sheriff
yeah okay but you got an actual court
summons okay all right yes and I
answered the summons and then we I got a
paper in the mail of the hearing okay
when's the hearing um January 10th okay
all right this um let me let's kind of
walk through a couple things here um
because information in these situations
I found when it's me if I get more
information some of the cobwebs move
away and some of the fear moves
away okay so to start with your absolute
worst wor case scenario is you do
nothing or go over to the hearing if you
want to you're going to
lose at the hearing okay okay there's no
no defense for this other than one idea
I've got in a minute but uh if you just
went to the hearing and just sat there
you're going to kind of giggle when you
leave have you ever gotten a ticket and
they say go to traffic court to get the
ticket torn
up um I think so yeah yeah I mean it's
kind of a funny thing it's almost like
Judge Judy but without the
personality okay you know it's like it's
kind of automatic it's boring it's no
there's no drama there's no TV cameras
or lights this is not OJ Simpson on
trial it's a traffic ticket for God's
sakes okay so what happens is this
attorney that's representing JP Morgan
is he runs a factory a large Factory you
are one of 10,000 widgets on the
conveyor belt this is
boring it's not like he personally is
angry with you or even knows you
freaking
exist he Wheels a two-wheeler into the
court or the equivalent of that with a
computer download of a bunch of files no
one shows up and the judge rules and
gives every one of them a judgment
instantly it's really
boring okay because it's really an open
shut case you owe money you didn't pay
it you lose
okay now they have a judgment lean
against you which means they could try
to attach your property if you own any
or your bank account or if you had a job
they which you don't that a traditional
job they could go after and garnish your
wages okay so to start my point is Don't
Panic about January 10th okay okay it's
kind of a yawn now we do have to deal
with this mess CU it's going to keep
poking you in in the side of the head
until you deal with it all right now how
are we going to deal with it well we're
going to deal with it one of two ways
one is uh I don't know if it'll work
because you you've waited around too
long to deal with it but basically you
are the victim of identity
theft even though your husband at the
time a husband does not have a right to
sign his wife's
signature by marriage that doesn't give
you that right okay I if I sign Sharon's
signature that's
fraud right if I have a power of
attorney from her to do that that's
different but he didn't so this is just
like a criminal on the street signed
your name up and got an $88,000 credit
card you don't owe the money because
you're a victim of identity theft now I
don't know if you're going to be able to
pull that off because you weighed around
if you had reported it a after you left
the abusive situation and gone ahead and
gotten a police report at the time it
might have worked
right so here's what I would do I'd call
the attorney on the summons and say I'm
in the process of filing a police report
I was in an abusive relationship and
I've just discovered that I am the
victim of identity theft I did not sign
this card and I am not liable for it I'm
putting you on notice of that I'll be in
touch with you and send you the police
report uh because you'll have to file a
police report and sign affidavit that
says you did not sign for the card a
criminal did someone stole your identity
oh by the way his name is and his
address is and they will do nothing
about it so never
fear okay but that's that's what
happened okay it's as if a stranger
signed your name to a card you follow me
yes since you did not sign it now the
fact that you've tinkered around with it
for three years and not done this
earlier is going to work against you in
proving the fact that you're a victim of
identity theft but hopefully you can get
it pushed through all right if that's
the case you owe nothing technically
legally morally you owe nothing
practically I don't know if you're going
to get through that or not the second
thing is if you can't get through that
offer them 2,000 bucks to settle it
settled in full but that's after you
fight with them for a while hold on I'm
going to have Austin pick up we're going
to put you in touch with the Xander
Insurance identity theft people and see
if they'll take your case and help you
run this down and get this uh identity
theft removed a as a favor to us
obviously if you were one of their
clients they would take care of you but
we're going to ask them to do it for us
hold
[Music]
on well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's Nets Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us netw week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Dr John delone joins me this hour he's
my co-host although I didn't let him say
a word last segment it's probably better
for America Dave it's probably better
hey I did have a question can I ask you
a question about that last call yeah
let's talk about that um so I've had
this back in my credit card in not
paying my bills days and I get this call
a lot on the show walk somebody through
the difference between the letter you
get when the credit card company sends
you a letter it looks like it's from a
law office and says you're being sued
versus actually being sued one of those
feels like a scam like a strong strong
arm technique the other is an actual
legal proceeding yeah and even the
actual legal proceeding is a walk
through is pretty much like traffic TR
it's a bit of a joke so it's not like
mattlock or Perry Mason is going going
to be down there and there's going to be
some intimidating person on the stand
and there's going to be a secret witness
none of that happens okay it's just I
was going say I did I did go to rural
Tennessee to take care of a traffic
ticket and it was pretty exciting was it
it was it was pretty exciting that's a
little different that Jud that judge is
a little bored and he's it was exciting
he saw a a guy roll up with a PhD or two
no I just I sat back in the back and
there was there was I I learned a lot
about the community I was where I got
the
ticket okay more than you wanted to very
different than I whose cousin was dating
whose cousin it was it was incredible
incredible oh that's fun so uh the
collections industry functions on one
thing the only effective tool they have
is
fear their job is to activate fear and
anything they can do in the whole
process to activate fear it is the best
chance they have of getting the bill
paid okay it's not loving kindness it's
not working through the logic of your
budget it's not hearing the story about
your mom who has cancer they don't care
it's all about fear and so cutting you
off in mid sentence uh one company even
uses people
from uh a different
region to call for instance they might
have Northerners with a New York accent
call Southerners because it's abrasive
to a southerner or vice versa because
it's abive
and uh so they'll do anything they can
they'll pull up a zip code on it and you
know pull a different person in they
even give them names I had one calling
me calling me her name was Mrs
Baskerville as in the hounds
of another one called me her name was
Mrs Savage Oh well done so um and I told
her I said that's the greatest name ever
she's like that's my real name and I
said no it's not but that's great I got
to hand it to you cuz once I kind of got
up behind the scenes and started
studying the collections business I what
they were doing it is a massive game
they're in a it's a person that can't
get a good job sitting in a cubicle with
a headset all day long yelling at people
screaming at them trying to get them to
do stuff so they threaten to file suit
they say we're about to file suit
tomorrow we have filed suit they send
emails that say that all of that is a
lie that's why I was asking her so many
questions I want to see if she'd
actually gotten served and actually had
a date at a hearing which she did she
has been sued okay but n out of 10 times
people call this show they've not been
sued they've been promised they've been
sued they told they were getting sued
I'm suing you today all of that no
lawsuit none whatsoever because a lot of
that debt isn't even collectable it's
out outside the statute of limitations
or or some other reason they can't get
out the debt so they're just yelling
screaming making a big loud noise to try
to get the little child inside of us to
be fearful and send them a check um even
people will pay bills they don't owe
sometimes like they'll call a a a mother
an elderly mother of someone and
intimidate her yell at her that her
son's going to jail if she doesn't pay
his bill and she'll pay the bill I've
had I've had them call is a nasty
business that is outside of the law at
most of the time federal fair debt
collection practices act prohibits
almost all of the activities they do on
a daily basis it is an outof control
nasty industry there is a small small
percentage of the collection's business
that is a local Hometown collection
agency that's collecting for the local
Hometown pest control or doctor and they
are usually pretty good people but
they're like 2% of the people in the
business the rest of them are just scum
all right so their job is to yell and
scream at you flap their arms and act
like that the you know we coming to take
you away haha you know and all this and
so that's what you've got to do is get
the other side of the fear and just go
really this is I'm one case in 10,000
this guy's dealing at this that day
there's probably 5 to 10,000 cases going
through there there's also as you're
talking I keep also having this nagging
other side which
is pay your freaking Bill well this
money doesn't go away right yeah I got a
single mom there that's been abused
that's right she's making 1,300 bucks a
month okay so yeah if she told me she
had $8,000 in the bank I would
have or in her situation she didn't even
owe it cuz it was identity theft call
and that's scary and I know there's a
whole other thickie
here here's the problem with her
situation and it comes up too it goes
under that same heading though is folks
when you have something like that in the
closet a 100% of the time it's going to
come out of the closet and visit you at
the exact wrong moment right 5 years
from now two years from now just after
you got married to that sweet little
thing and you're getting ready to buy a
house oh crap back when I was in college
drunk all the time I never dealt dealt
with this car wreck and I still owe
$1,400 to freaking State Farm and they
finally find me now that I'm acting like
a legitimate citizen 100% of the time
you don't deal with this crap it has a
high rate of Resurrection it will come
back to life in the zombie form and at
the worst possible time and it's harder
to deal with then so when you have a
problem deal with it right then right
cuz it's a lot harder for her to clear
this up four years later
right if she dealt with it after she
moves out from Ab
abusive criminal theft identity theft
boy if she'd have turned him in
instantly filed a police report then and
been very proactive but that's hard to
do for someone been in an abusive
situation I get that yeah she's not
feeling really confident and cocky right
she's not got a lot of swag all that's
real all that's real still if you can
find any kind of something down inside
of you to bust into it and deal with it
at the moment
right then but when you wait 2 years
it's hard for the judge to look at you
and have sympathy when you wait three
years here's the hard truth you will
have the conversation about hey he stole
my card you can do it now or you can
have it later or you can do it four
years from now and then not be believed
you can pay a bill you don't know
because you're still living because
you're still sitting in fear absolutely
you're still sitting in Brokenness from
that abuse right and so our job is to
give you courage due to knowledge and
due to inspiration to go ahead and deal
with everything now and we're only
telling you if you're find yourself if
you're you've exited an abusive
relationship if you're over your head
and you just haven't been able to pay
we're telling you this because we love
you it's going to come the if even if
you have to find a buddy that will sit
with you and make that call with you or
will help you do whatever you got to do
because you're going to have those hard
conversations the earlier you have them
the better Runway you have to deal with
it yeah it's it is so much easier to
clean up before it grows right but it
get tentacles it grows it grows all
inside the closet and you have to put
yourself in the eye of that I mean in
the in the seat of that judge how many
people of those 10,000 people say I
didn't that wasn't me 999 I mean 9,999
of them right and you know I got to tell
you her going in filing a police report
on an ex-boyfriend that was or
ex-husband that was abusive that's an
act of Courage on her part cuz she's
poking The Beehive that is super super
scary yeah so she's either going to do
that or she's going to pay the bill
she's going to pay $8,000 yeah and does
that suck all the way around abs
everything there sucks the whole thing
does yeah so but the deal is don't let
these people intimidate you they're an
idiot in a cubicle 500 miles away that
couldn't get a good
job okay cleaning septic tanks is much
more
honorable at least you're doing Humanity
some good hey those guys that clean my
sep tank you and you don't have to lie
to do your job okay and so the don't let
these people set the tone you set the
tone just laugh about it and go all
you're cute you're just so cute and
listen if you don't calm down a little
bit I'm going to just let you talk to Mr
dial tone you're going to hear a little
click and this whole thing going to go
away little click you ready little click
here we go okay and I just started
messing with him man I got I reached the
point that I'd studied them so much that
it it was like a fun game it's like the
guy calls up to sell you the uh Andy
Ander did this the other day guy called
him up to sell him one of the auto uh
what do you call the um extended
warranties car he didn't own right and
he's he's he acted like he was 85 years
old yeah I got me one I don't even have
that car but you sound like a nice young
man could I sign up for this anyway you
know he messes with him he just had a
good time it's a great YouTube video you
ought to pull it up but yeah you got to
do it you got to have a way of looking
at it that's where they don't own you
emotionally it's your only shot at
getting your arms around this and
winning and that's what we're here to do
is to help you do that not to not pay
your bill the idea is if you owe the
bill we're going to have help you pay it
too but we also don't want them to be in
control of your
[Music]
[Applause]
life hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
[Applause]
more
Dr John delone Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Ranna is in Lynchburg
Virginia hi Ranna welcome to the show
how can we
helpo um so my husband and I we've been
saving up money for about a year and a
half now looking to build or buy a home
um and we're trying to decide if that is
the right thing to do um because I still
have student loan
payments okay or not payments but
student loan debt I how how much student
loan debt do you
have about 40,000 and how much money
have you
saved um so far we saved about a little
over 15,000 okay and what's your
household
income um together we make about
86,000 good good what do youall do for a
living
so I'm a high school teacher and my
husband is an admissions counselor at a
local University great very cool okay
all right well um you're apparently
fairly new to all this Ramsey stuff is
that
true yes okay all right well what we
have discovered in 30 years of helping
people become wealthy is the shortest
distance between where you are and
Wealthy which home ownership is a good
step in the direction of becoming
wealthy the shortest distance is to be
debt-free
have an emergency fund of 3 to six
months of
expenses buy a home then start getting
your uh retirement plans going and then
get the home paid off and that's like a
five or a 10e plan I just laid out right
there okay um what we have found is that
when people buy a home with $40,000 in
student loan debt that it activates
every negative thing that can happen in
your life because Sally May is living in
the spare bedroom student loan has its
own bedroom and the heat and air unit
goes out the roof leaks and the hot
water heater goes
out and you have no
money so what we've taught people to do
and it's very unpopular with people who
have house fever because buying a house
is a good thing but buying a house when
you're a broke person is not a good
thing that's why they call them brokers
so um you need to get a house but you
need to get one after you get rid of
your student loan debt is what we would
tell you and that's so that the house is
a blessing to you and not a
curse um not what you wanted to
hear I I do agree with that and that's
ideally what we would like to do however
I think our situation is kind of what
makes that a challenge um we live in a
one-bedroom apartment with one son we
want to start growing our family soon
and the apartment that we live in has
people have families that rent all the
time move yeah hey Ranna I did what you
what you're talking about my wife was a
teacher and she had about $20,000 in
student loan debt and lucky for her she
was married to an associate DEA students
at a local University who had about
$888,000 worth the student loan that so
combined we had six
figures and I had to have a house cuz we
were having a new
baby and I went Stone
mad because the math never
worked and we ended up selling our house
and I moved into a residence hall with a
2-year-old and a wife to get out of debt
to get out of debt and so I with all of
my heart please rent please don't add
this additional strain to to a young
family trying to start new careers
especially as one as chaotic as the
world your husband's in college
admissions right now my gosh start
tutoring start doing side work and and
rent as cheap as you can and get the
40,000 paid off in one year live on
beans and rice rice and beans don't eat
out don't go on vacation get the
stinking student loan debt out of your
life and then save up and go buy you a
house I want you to get a house but I
don't want you to be cursed by the
ownership of this house because you
Justified it in the name of a baby don't
do that if you don't want to live in a
one-bedroom fine go rent a two-bedroom
whoopty
dupty uh I mean lots of people do that I
want to say it as directly as possible
the math doesn't care what you want and
we're in a one-bedroom apartment with a
one with with a toddler I can't imagine
how scary that is but dude um we want to
start growing our family well you can't
afford it yet or you can't afford a
house you going to have to start renting
you're going have to make some hard
choices pay that debt off man yeah just
because I I want a bigger house for my
family doesn't mean math takes a break
right Jen is in De Mo Iowa hi Jen
welcome to the ramsy
show hi hey what's
up all right so I've got a question for
you my husband works in the tech field
currently and we have about $80,000 in
stocks that are vested and I was
wondering if it would be a good idea to
pull those out and to put that amount
onto our mortgage to pay it off faster
yes today
that was easy hooray easy you you want
to know how I did that so fast is I just
reverse engineer everything they call it
a sunk cost analysis I say if uh what do
you owe on your home
today we owe
$184,000 okay if you owed $100,000 on
your home today and didn't own stock
would you go refinance your home and
borrow an extra 80,000 to buy stock no
no well it's the same thing we're just
doing it
backward okay yeah that's that's
incredibly easier than I thought it was
going
toada yeah that's that's how I did that
show quickly but and that's why I wanted
to teach it to you too so you can do
that with anything if you have a boat in
the driveway that's worth $88,000 you
say if I had $8,000 in the kitchen table
and I didn't have that boat would I go
buy it no well then sell the boat okay
you know or yes I love the boat then
keep the boat that's okay but that you
just do a reverse analysis of where you
are today and pretend there that many
Benjamin sitting in the middle of your
kitchen table and go would I buy stock
or would I pay off my well I pay down
the mortgage where that gets dicey is
when my wife looks at me sitting at the
kitchen table and she says would I do
that again
no then I'm kind of stuck man um hey I
will say this when you when you start
Cashing Out stock at your company his
co-workers will look at him weird or the
people ask him hard questions they just
don't get a vote that that I'm not even
telling it's another business it falls
under the N yeah but it's a na you know
I don't have to talk about it it's just
like you know in the old days people
didn't talk about their money yeah they
do now I know they talk about everything
now yeah I know I mean a certain
generation grew up they didn't think
their parents had sex or money turns out
they'd had both they you so you know
because we never talked about it right
just little bits of each Dave just
little bits the bare minimum the bare
minimum Stevens in Dallas Texas hey
Steph how are you hi I'm doing really
good thank you good how can we help so
I'm just trying to perplex on how I'm
going to pay for a doctorate loan my
girlfriend who I'm engaging in the next
month is um going through Doctorate of
chiropracting School here in August and
uh I just need to know the best way to
kind of save up slash you know how
should I how much debt is she going into
to be a
chiropractor um about 200,000 holy Jesus
just don't is she she's already done
it no she she leaves for school in
August as a guy who worked in higher
education for 20 years please don't do
that and I know you don't we're not
going to talk you out of this yeah but
dude the ROI on this the average
chiropractor makes 60,000
bucks okay I mean it doesn't make any
sense we do in that sense it's not it's
not worth
$200,000 your here's y'all need to do
some research into Chiropractic and
actually understand what's going on out
there I've worked with broke
chiropractors for
years they're
everywhere
man I I would tell you as her boyfriend
um I would not start coming up with a
plan to pay off her student loans yet um
unfortunat I know in your situation
everything's going to be perfect but we
wouldn't have a show if people didn't
have great plans it didn't work out our
whole show is made up of people who got
engaged and then started taking care of
something for their their new husband or
wife and then it goes sideways and so I
would hold off on making up a plan to
pay off her student loans until you are
married well and I also would like to
start having some real serious
discussions if you're getting engaged as
to whether she's going to go $200,000 in
debt to be a chiropractor yeah I got to
tell you that's what I I strongly
recommend you don't do that if you want
to go into Chiropractic fine but don't
go 200 Grand in debt to do it there is
no math that says that's smart none
nowhere I mean you can get an MD for 200
grand for God's sakes you can actually
Roi that this is the ramsy
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable ass set and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too to long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
apply
[Music]
[Applause]
our question of the day is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services the holidays are over but your
house may not look like it how'd you
know so you need Junk King for that
dying tree toys that have broken already
and the boxes they came in go to
neighbor.com Ramsey and contact a junk
King near you to get that post holiday
stuff I am calling Ramy right now cuz my
wife's birthday's coming up and I said
what do you want she said I want one of
those bins to show up in the back of our
house to get rid of this old crummy boat
you bought off Craigs List and so I'm
calling them today today's question
comes from from Taylor in Indiana Taylor
writes this is a question for Dave and
delone I recently paid off a 100,000
bucks in student loans during the last
three years way to go I'm proud of
myself for the personal discipline and
fulfillment for fi for my financial
commitments towards repaying the loans
good I used my education to have a
successful professional career and want
to encourage others at the same as
possible and worth it for him I feel a
great sense of relief but I'm afraid to
tell my family my mother feels entitled
to be quote unquote paid back for being
a parent and has actually stolen
thousands of dollars from me in the past
I genuinely feel sad that I'll never
hear that she's proud of me and Wishes
the best for my future with her without
her handout expectantly is it wrong for
me to lie about my accomplishments and
pretend to be broke in order to
financially and emotionally protect
myself also would you mind sharing what
you might say as a parent since I'll
never hear it from my own wow
H um I'm going to answer this in a
couple different ways Dave hop
in um I don't think lying is ever a good
idea I also think there's a middle
ground
between
um entering into conversations parading
around um I here's the deal I don't want
you to bring down your sense of dignity
and your sense of character and your
sense of respectability by choosing to
lie take the low road at the same time
no
this mother who's stolen from you who is
actively looking to steal from you again
who expects to be refunded for her
parenting um she has no claim on your
life right none none and so um I don't
think you talk about it how's it work
works
good um where why are you driving that
car well that's that's because I wanted
to that's the car I I was able to buy
well where's my car well I I I paid for
that one in cash so that was my car
budget
and where's my car I don't know when you
go get one yeah when you get one when
you start developing boundaries what
you're going to find is it's like a
muscle and you get real strong real fast
exactly and when you tell somebody no
and they start to him and Han and John
and you get rid of you you stand tall
through that first initial wave that
assault that comes up against your Gates
then you realize oh I
stood and it's just going to be that
way so here's the deal as long as you
have to hide from her she still has
power of over
you it's not it's not she no longer
should have power over you yeah and so
it's just because all you have to do is
just say no just you know Mom I love you
I'm not going to do
that if you're going to keep talking
like that we're going to opt out of this
conversation and I'm going to have to
walk
away I'm walking away now it's all you
can do you just have to set a boundary
but you don't have to lie and you don't
have to let her have power power over
you but it's also it's also smart and
wise on your part which you have done to
recognize this is not a person who is
going to celebrate with you your
incredible accomplishment for which any
parent should be very proud but your
mom's messed
up I'm sorry it's sad when your mom's
messed up but sometimes moms are messed
up and so yours is definitely I almost
99% of the time I'll and I'll tell you
this Taylor I would sit down and um
write my mom three different letters
that I'm never going to send her I'd
write her a letter and this one's going
to be hard to tell her how how grateful
you are for what she gave you and she
may have given you some really thick
skin she may have given you a bunch of
hurdles that you had to figure out a way
over but there is some good that is in
your life because of this interaction
this relationship I want you read a
second letter that says that starts with
dear
Mom you should have done a better job
you should have loved me and and I want
you to demine your soul for that stuff
it's heavy and it's hard the third
letter was is um should be one of
freedom and relief and a little bit of
grief is here's who you're going to miss
here's what you're going to
miss and you begin to teach your body
that it wasn't okay that like Dave just
said she had power over me and I'm
letting that power go here's what you're
going to miss and I'm not going to
diminish myself and I'm not going to be
a person of lesser character to try to
avoid you anymore as Dave said you don't
get vote anymore yeah you opted out and
um so I just really the point is I
wouldn't I wouldn't lie but I wouldn't
expect a celebration I just wouldn't
bring it up just it's just something you
get to do for yourself and um you know
one of the things I did Taylor also is
uh years ago gosh it's 20 plus years ago
now and I attribute it as one of about
five things that caused uh this
organization to be inordinately
successful was I got uh the first group
I called them a group of eagles cuz
Eagles don't flock you have to pull them
together and I got a group of men that
were strong
spiritually strong in their
marriages they were successful very
successful in business or in their
chosen career two of them were pastors
of huge churches uh one of them was a
multitime bestell bestselling author and
so on in the room and we met every
Wednesday morning for a Bible studies
what we first started calling it then we
started just reading books and that went
on for 14 years and I'm telling you all
that to say one of the rules in that
room was that's a group of guys that
were high Achievers and we wanted to be
a safe place to
brag you got to be able to tell the good
stuff cuz there's not everybody you
can't brag in front of that's right
because it's bragging but you need to be
able to come in and go just freaking won
the Super Bowl by God yes you know and
you got to have somebody that loves you
enough in the room that's going to own
that with you that you respect their
opinion that you can share that with
especially since your mom's not one of
them or they didn't they don't feel
threatened by it yeah they're not
threatened they're there to celebrate
with you and that's one of our rules and
it's it we want you to we want you to
come in here and brag when something
really good is going on or when you do
something really good for your spouse
want you to come here and brag about it
and that really lasted uh and I've got
another group of guys I run with today
and that's one of the rules in that
group too and so when something good
happens or something super bad happens
you can bring it in too but um yeah
Taylor you need to have some guys around
that can celebrate with you cuz your
mom's not ever going to be able to do
that she doesn't have the capacity she's
too broken and she should have but she
should you should have a mom that
celebrates you and you don't everybody
should and dude by the way our lady I
don't know what kind of tayor it is man
woman it could be either one um Taylor
you paid off
$100,000 you have a successful
professional career we're proud of you
we think you're amazing big time way to
go big time way to go do the Snoopy
dance man nose up ears out dance here we
go have it baby enjoy the ride do it and
don't let her steal that and you don't
have to go into someone's presence and
cow meaning they have power over you and
you have to bow down by lying or by
enabling or participating in their
dysfunction you just have to smile and
kind of shake your head and go gosh
that's awful sad it's awful sad that's
just really sad mama can't do that
that's sad no not doing that sorry sad I
um Dave it took me a long time this go
this is reason we're going on with this
is because it's almost everybody out
everybody I know
um we have a generation I I heard this
recently Dave someone saying I'm talking
about kids and it was really a brilliant
response it was uh an older psychologist
who was pretty frustrated he said I
don't want to hear it again that the
kids of this generation have changed
kids are kids it's the parents of these
kids that have changed you know I was at
a I was at a FCA banquet with Bobby
Bowen one time years ago and I asked him
I said so how much of the kids changed
since you've been coaching you know 500
years since the
1960s said the kids hadn't changed the
parents are Crazy Dads that's right the
kids are still doing the same exact
stupid stuff the kids have always done
College college football players are
doing exact same stupid stuff but the
parents are nuttier in Fruit Cakes man
because used to the parents are somewhat
of an anchor but so they're they've lost
their dadgum minds that's right find
somebody you can tell the positive stuff
to please everybody yeah share it share
it with them and don't don't with her
but don't lie she doesn't have power
over you anymore this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
la
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's the
host of the Dr John delone show on
podcast you ought to check it out it's
unbel believably popular talks about
mental health issues and relationship
issues there and all kinds of other fun
things it's very entertaining you ought
to be sure you're there he's here to
help you today and so am I the phone
number is
5225 Jordan Is With Us in Springfield
Illinois hi Jordan how are you good how
are you Dave better than I deserve
what's up hey uh so I've got a quick
question for you U my wife and I we're
28 I'm an Illinois state trooper she's a
nurse we bring home around 8,00 a month
um I discovered you September last year
I sold my truck that was paid off for
32,000 paid off uh my student loans and
our rings so that leaves us with about
$45,000 left in student loans and the
$280,000 mortgage good for you you're
heading on the right way J that's
awesome man welcome to the gang thank
you I'm I'm excited to to be in this
journey but um I have a little bit of a
problem in October of last year my
parents announced they were getting a
divorce and my father told me I'm now
responsible for the 60,000 Parent PLUS
Loan um there have been maybe two
payments on it in six years I've tried
to have conversations with them about it
it always gets real hostile he gets
defensive he defers the blame to my mom
stating that he never had anything to do
with the loans in the first place and
that my mother handled everything with
the loan I know I'm not legally
accountable for the loan um but every
time I bring it up he's always like
you're the that went to school so I I I
do feel a little accountable um okay was
there a
conversation back
then that you made a contract with your
dad and mom verbally to promise to pay
this not to my knowledge I mean we've
talked about it I don't believe so okay
so your mom and dad were trying to help
you out they took out a Parent PLUS Loan
did you had
no reason to believe you had to repay
that until your Dad decided later that
you did is that the actual facts correct
okay all right then it's on your dad
okay should I add it to the snowball I
no it's not your dad okay okay dude
you're trying to preserve a relationship
like you're thinking in your head I
don't want to I don't want to mess this
relationship up your dad has already
done that yeah he's the one who's chosen
to take out his frustration with your
mom on his
son right I mean he he yeah that's a
good good way to put it that's not your
game to play that's not your mess yeah
your mom did this and I'm getting read
of
her whoa right that's strong because if
he had a real problem with it he should
have settled it in court well the the
other big issue I have is he's got
140,000 in his in his uh Ira tired you
stay out of his head and out of his
checking accounts too okay right like
you're going to make yourself crazy
trying to do dad math on his money he
signed the or just your mom it's just in
his
name okay then how did how did she do it
without his knowledge if he signed it he
literally said he said I've never seen a
document about that I wouldn't even know
what it looks like that's between him
and your mom that's not between him and
you right yeah absolutely yeah you know
I I you you didn't have do with this you
were just at school and they were paying
for part of it and your mom I I I think
your mom made a
mistake uh but there's a lot of mistakes
in this story between your mom and dad
mhm and so um uh but I don't think it's
your responsibility to take on their
mistake let's pretend it wasn't a loan
let's just say she took money out of
their joint checking account and just
paid for part of your
school would you have to pay that back
if you didn't have any knowledge that
you were supposed to pay that back no
it's the same
thing absolutely and here's my equally I
mean there's that issue your dad's
changing the rules he's starting to
revisit history here but more so rewrite
history he won't have a grownup
man-to-man conversation with his son
who's a State
Trooper he won't sit across a table and
say son this divorce is killing me I
don't have the money to pay
$60,000 um I know made an agreement with
you I can we re like he won't do that he
makes you feel stupid and small because
of a decision him and his wife made when
you were 18 years old right when I
didn't have any idea what I was getting
into exactly right exactly and I hate
that for you dude because he's gonna
make you the bad guy in this and you're
not you're not I mean it's it's bringing
issues in in my marriage and I just your
wife thinks you'd be crazy to pay it
that's the issue yes yeah yes sounds
like you married
well hey and by the way your dad is the
one opting out a future holidays not you
thank thank you for reassuring me of
that because I mean yeah he's welcome
he's welcome if he can behave if you act
like a grown up decision yeah but if you
want to if you want to run away on
$60,000 then we now know the value of
your relationship with your son sir
right you think we know we we now know
the price tag it's 60 Grand right so
just Stand My Ground and yeah hon here's
the thing if you said you if you told
them you were going to pay it we'd be
sitting here telling you to pay it
absolutely yeah okay I want to tell I
want to you to change your language a
little bit I don't even know if it's a
Stand My Ground I'm walking
away gotcha
um yeah it's too long to tell the story
I I'm finding more and more value in the
times I plant my feet on a hill and I'm
ready to die on that Hill as old as I'm
getting older are just getting smaller
smaller and if someone wants to lie
about me they want to throw a debt on me
that I don't owe they want to take out
their frustration about their failed
marriage on me I'm I'm dude I can't
engage in that I'm walking away yeah
have a good day yeah have a good day and
I know that sounds bad but I want we're
we're a Jordan your estate Trooper
around here we're most of us are gun
guys and a bunch of us have done
tactical training and the first thing we
learn in tactical training is run get
out
run don't engage Wick is a movie it's
not reality run bullets hurt run get
away that's the first goal and instead
of instead you know John Wayne John Wick
whoever we're not we don't need to be
John yeah so um we got guys like Jordan
to take care of this right so uh and
that's you know that's kind of what
John's uh John delone is saying the only
John that the real John right but yo do
you mind if I ask you another quick
question real real fast real fast yeah
real fast so we're both contributing 500
a month to our IRA would stop that until
you're out of debt perfect that's what I
was going to ask you temporarily when
you're on baby step two you stop all
investing temporarily to totally focus
on a singular goal and Jordan this is
going to be hard for you with your dad
cuz he's your
dad and you can be sad and you can be
kind you can be strong but you're not
going to convince him that you're right
the only thing you can do is just pull
back pull back give him room while he's
in this wounded State he's a wounded
animal right now and um just give him
room just give him room and someday
he'll come around or he won't that'll be
on him though it won't be on you I'm
sorry you're facing this it's a hard
thing but you don't know the money sir
and your wife is right this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt sell company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Dr John delone Ramsey personality is my
co-host today January the 11th you and
200,000 of your closest friends can join
us so far
227,000 people have signed up for the
free live stream break the cycle Dr John
deloney Jade warshaw Dave
Ramsey uh Rachel Cruz George camel were
going to help you break the cycle did
you know that stupid has a gravitational
pull I was going to make a joke about
sitting next to you but I
won't too late you did too late too late
yeah I don't know which one is the
gravitational pull which one is the
stupid but we'll go with that so either
way it does it it stupid will pull you
back in and you have to break the cycle
it requires an effort to break an orbit
when you're in orbiting stupid you know
it takes energy to bust an orbit to bust
out of an orbit and break free of the
gravitational B pull of something and
that's what break the cycle is all about
we're going to help you do that it's
time you can't blame the family curse
anymore you can't blame well people like
me people in my neighborhood no it's you
we're going to help you do it we're
going to help you face the person in
your mirror and go be the person you've
always dreamed you should be and could
be we're going to walk you into that
handheld High here we go January the
11th go to ramsy solutions.com and sign
up for break the cycle it's completely
free and uh we're going to be going a
couple hours there so settle in get some
popcorn get some pizza get ready we're
going to do this and uh it's going to be
an incredible podcast the or our live
I'm you know we've been reviewing all
the material and putting it all together
for this getting ready for about 90 days
and uh uh it's going to be the largest
live stream we've ever done it appears
like we're probably going to have 3 to
500,000 folks watching this that night
and so um come and join us we'd love to
have you it is completely free there is
no obligation oh and we're going to give
away $10,000 10 of you will get $11,000
of the of the people viewing not the
people who sign up the people that are
watching that Night Live we're going to
give out we're going to show you how to
do it that night and 10 different people
are going to get a th000 bucks so Ramsey
solutions.com
click break the cycle Logan in Lexington
Kentucky hi Logan how are you good Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up Hey so uh real fast I'll give you a a
backstory of where I'm at today um uh
April 22 uh my wife and I got married
before we got married I had about
$30,000 in my bank account she had
$5,000 student loan and uh $177,000 car
note um pretty much as soon as we got
married paid that off got that out Al
took care of um we then um rented an
apartment for a year and uh decided we
were going to stay there um until we had
enough money to put a good down payment
on a house um unfortunately after that
year
um we had an opportunity uh present
itself to buy a home from a family
friend at a pretty well discounted price
well below what the home value was um we
knew that it was too much house for us
it's a 4,200 Square ft house
$315,000 is what we paid for it um
firsttime home buyer so we didn't have
any money to put down 0% Downs that we
got um 6.25% interest rate um we knew it
was going to be a lot but we tried any
anyway uh we live there up until
November of this past year barely making
it living paycheck to paycheck um
struggling our marriag was struggling we
just decided we can't do this anymore if
if we want this to work and we do um so
we end up putting the house up for sale
um sold the house in seven days um for
$415,000 so $100,000 more than we gave
for it in
March um after realtor fees etc etc we
uh walked away with
$77,000 um within the time that we lived
in the home we accumulated $10,000 with
a credit card de updating the home um it
was built in 2002 so it was very
outdated and to try to get that uh home
value up even more to sell it we put
$10,000 on a credit card via you know
furniture for us and then fencing and
new flooring C Etc um today um I have
right at $50,000 in the bank $22,000 of
that 77 I bought my wife a car um we
just found out in Christmas that on
Christmas day that she's pregnant and do
her first baby um I'm 26 she's
25 um I have a car note for $37,500 what
I owe on it um so now we have three
vehicles two are paid off one truck that
I have is not paid off 37,500 what I owe
on it um the reason what are you smoking
that you go buy a $37,000 car after you
just sold a house house because you
couldn't
breathe no it was 22,000 is what I paid
for her car I already had the $37,000
car Lo before what do you guys make a
year uh 130 together good
Lord okay yeah like I said I've had the
what can I do help you got ticket dude
and you blew your nose in it that's what
you did man what can you what
can how come you got $50,000 in the bank
after you sell both cars and pay your
capital gains you're probably even
right yeah that's the thing I don't know
how much the capital gain percentage is
um it's it's not it's not a capital gain
it's ordinary income because you didn't
hold the house a year so it's a it's a
35% tax on the actual gain and the gain
is not 415 the gain is after sales
expenses and you probably did some
Capital Improvements on that credit card
debt that you can deduct as well so you
probably have a $7,000 gain at 35%
probably got a $20,000 tax bill you need
to sit down with a tax person and figure
out what that is but it's probably right
around there and you have cars you can't
afford and you went and bought another
one right go sell both of
them okay and you're not going to are
you no I I I I will I'm thinking what
I'm thinking is you know we live an hour
from work both of us when we live
grantree now on her grandparents estate
Unfortunately they passed away they had
a house here they didn't want to sell so
we're living here rentree
um so what does that mean you have to be
stupid with
cars no it rent free doesn't describe
stupid
cars right right so we're just trying to
decide should I sell my truck yes yes
you know get okay that's I'm you should
sell the car you just bought
her okay y'all are broke people
man yeah you're broke you make a
$130,000 a year and you've made a series
of bad financial decisions that have
caused you to be broke
the best way to do it is go back to the
last time you were standing on Solid
Ground which is when you had a couple of
junky cars that were paid for and
$100,000 cash in the bank yeah that was
a while back but yeah yeah get let's get
rid of both of these get the most get
the best car you can get for cash know
and figure out what your capital gains
are so the $222,000 car you bought her
did you use the $50,000 cash to do that
or did you go get a loan on that no no
no we we had 77,000 in the bank oh so
now you got 50 after buying that car so
that car is paid for yeah both we have
two cars that are paid for and one car
that one truck my truck is not okay so
both of our cars are paid for oh good
then just get rid of the truck get rid
of the truck and pay the capital
gains right that that was my main
question yeah okay I'm caught up with
you now yeah but dude you got to quit
buying crap you don't go buy a $22,000
car when you walk out of this disaster
you just came from it literally I mean
it's the exact conversation you just had
about breaking the cycle you do you like
we can't breathe we got to sell this
house we sold the house hey we got some
money let's go buy let's go buy a car
let's buy a car oh let's get pregnant
and then buy another car and it's like
oh I can't breathe again well what are
we going to do now we got to sell the
car and do this and do this hey we got
some more money let's go get up yeah
it's like thank God it's Friday oh God
it's Monday yeah we're in this rentree
house well you know it's got to have new
floors and a new roof and a new this
let's put on the credit card we'll just
pay it off later we don't even have a
house payment I think you could be dead
free if you sell the truck mhm and pay
your capital gains and pay off the
credit card and chop them up and then
you're going to have to make a decision
to never do the stupid crap you've been
doing for the past three years you have
to do man when I went broke Logan I was
your age and I had to sit down and do an
autopsy a CSI on Dave and I looked at
all the stupid butt stuff Dave was doing
and had to go if you want to live like
this you can keep doing the stupid butt
stuff or I can stop doing the stupid
butt stuff and have a better life and
that's why I'm yelling at you cuz I love
you I want you to win dude this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medic IAL event
chm has been a godsend for Jenna that's
her chm story and it could be yours
learn more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey guys uh just a couple
weeks ago we hit number one on Apple
podcast of all podcasts in the entire
world that's pretty cool uh we've been
hovering up around 10 11 12 we've been
up at 7 a couple times 5 never number
one and we hit number one I don't know
where we are today it changes I think
daily or hourly or whatever but uh we
did make that Milestone and we want to
say thank you to you guys CU it's you
that did it we appreciate you and we'll
ask you to continue doing what caused
that what caused that was more and more
of you are sharing the show you're
taking a link to the show or clicking
the share button you're subscribing
you're following whatever the format is
whether it's YouTube or uh local talk
radio station you're telling people
about whatever it is you're letting
people know you're leaving fstar reviews
you're sharing thank you for doing that
and please keep doing it it is the
biggest thing you can do to say thank
you to us and help us if you like what
you're hearing share it tell somebody
about it if you like what you're hearing
leave a festar review thank you if you
don't go somewhere else it's okay we
understand there's not everything not
we're not for everybody but uh we are
for folks that want to change their
lives want to learn something and that
want some people to tell them the truth
that love them and we're those people we
care about you we want you to win and
that's cheesy but it's also real and
thank you for hanging out with us we
appreciate the subscriptions we
appreciate the follows we appreciate the
nice reviews and we appreciate the
sharing Nick is in Lima Ohio hi Nick how
are
you hey Dave and John how are you guys
doing better than we deserve what's up
man yeah so I was wondering if you guys
could possibly gives me some words of
wisdom or thoughts on my wife returning
to
school okay what's she going to study so
she is looking at studying
Dentistry O
Okay so right now she is a dental
hygienist is making about $40,000 a year
um I'm a CPA I make about 75,000 a year
MH um right now we have 70,000
in student loan debt and that's on my
degree well she didn't aim small did
she no I mean have you priced a dental
degree yes um in Ohio there are only two
dental schools um in Ohio State which is
the cheaper of the two and I say cheaper
when quotes is going to C cost um right
around
$400,000 that's pretty typical yeah yep
so um we're looking to cash flow this
somehow um and pretty much the problem
we're running into is you know we're
projecting it's probably going to take
about two years probably to still pay
off the rest of my debt and then another
half year to save up the um
the uh fund whatever and then it's going
to probably be oh probably about two and
a half years worth of savings projected
cost of the dental school in order to
actually cash flow the whole thing with
just my
salary I'm confused how you're going to
pay off 35,000 a year for two years but
in two more years you're going to have
Grand no um we would cash flow out um
two of the dental school years so we
would save
up 200 200 yeah um and you're going to
borrow the other
200 no
um you're going to cash flow it as she
goes we're going to try and cash flow it
as she goes so pretty much we wouldn't
start until we had the
200,000 saved up so what's your
question well question is is would it be
worth it to do it even though she's
going to be 30 years old when she starts
and we're looking at a 35 year old GR
graduating dental school why does that
matter my mom graduated her PhD at 57
years old and was tenured by the time
she was
63 you pay cash for it she's going to be
making dentist money depending on what
kind of dental practice she gets into
the next thing you'll face is she'll
want to buy a practice and that's
another 500 or
400 the big challenge the question is
not is it worth going to school and her
not getting out until she's 30 the
question is 35 or 35 the question is
you're going to be 35 does she want to
be a dentist when she's 35 or
no but math doesn't care about your
timeline what what why does she want to
be a
dentist um kind of a threefold um
question almost she's worked for a few
dentists um she doesn't always agree
with how they want so she kind of wants
to do her own thing she wanted to be a
dentist originally but was kind of
afraid to do the time commitment then
but as she's worked in the actual field
she feels like being a dentist would be
a good thing for her is there any chance
somebody in the practice would sign her
to a five-year deal and pay for dental
school for
her um it's possible I'm not sure how
many small uh dental clinics around here
would go for that but there might be one
around here that'd be willing to do it
so here's what you've done real quick
you've put some
constraints she doesn't want to work at
a big one she wants to work at a small
one she we want a cash flow but she
doesn't want to be a dentist all the way
until she's 35 she wants to get it
sooner I want to do this but I don't
want to do that you'reall going to have
to make some sacrifices somewhere that
are going to be really hard you're
probably going to have to get another
job as a CPA only making 75 you're going
to need to double your income
somewhere and that might mean you got to
do corporate taxs are you going to take
on a bunch of Saturday and Sunday
private clients over the next months
Ohio State you're moving to
Columbus um probably in between she
would commute somewhat and then I would
commute someone's work we're not too far
away from Columbus yeah okay all right
y'all have
children yeah we have two of them uh one
is a year and a half and the other is
five months okay all right um there's no
harm in getting on this path you don't
pass the point of no return until she
actually starts dental
school until then you're just paying off
debt and saving up
money so we can get on that path and
then the question I guys I want you guys
to ask us a couple pretty regularly is I
don't want her to go through all this
and drop 400k into this and then decide
she wants to be a full-time
Mom okay I've I've talked to Lady MDS
I've talked to people on different kind
of situations um that that you know they
their their dream shifted about what
they saw their life being um after they
were already so far down the rabbit hole
on the education stuff and so it's not
to say she can't be a dentist I didn't
I'm not saying because she's female she
can't be a dentist because she's a mom
she can't be a dentist she can be I just
want to make sure really $400,000 worth
of sure that she's going to play all the
way through and work the rest of her
life as a dentist because that's that's
what this is for you're going to go
she's going to work 25 years as a
dentist when she comes out till she's 60
and uh every day going to work as a
dentist every day that's her job and
then this this rois but otherwise the
400k is absolutely
ludicrous to spend that and then not
work you know 20 years plus in the field
is ludicrous I think there's a valuable
exercise and y'all to making a very
committed debt payment plan to pay off
your student loans and see if that fire
and that excitement and that um desire
is still there yeah in 18 months or 24
months if you're willing to cash flow it
and she's willing to stick with it I'm
okay with it uh it's a it's not a bad
life plan I just run into too many
people who get too far into this and
then realize oh I don't think I want to
do that this is not this is not going to
a 6 months of $10,000 worth of
certificates on something and then
deciding you don't want to do it that
this is you know a big chunk of your
life and
$400,000 worth of sure you got to be
sure and uh it's a major commitment in
other words so um in the process of you
all getting out of Deb and building up
the first 200 we're going to ask that
question over and over again are you
sure building your calculations child
care for two little kids for the next 3
four 5 seven years yeah cuz that's going
to cost a lot too exactly this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Dr John delone Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Spencer is in Eugene
Oregon if I can can figure out how to
hit the right button here there we go
Spencer is in Eugene Oregon he Spencer
how are
you D John how are you guys better than
we deserve man what's up perfect well I
wanted to run a question by you guys um
so my wife and I have been married for
about 11 years of those 11 years I've
been working as a firefighter paramedic
for about eight of them uh my wife
recently brought to my attention that
she struggles with certain aspects of my
career to the point where she has
thought to ask me to change careers
uh she struggles with a thought of that
because she knows how much I absolutely
love my job what I do and where I work
as well as how well it pays for our
large family uh she's afraid that I
would resent her if I were to leave my
career and it would be the hardest thing
that I've ever done for sure because I
absolutely have no idea what else I
would do as my entire educational career
has led me to the point where I am now
uh she wants to explore options for
counseling and possibly help her through
what she's struggling with uh before we
explore the option of a career change
but we don't know where to start uh we
don't know if we want marriage
counseling or individual counseling so
we're just looking for some advice wh
which part of your uh job does she not
like or what parts does she not like um
so she has a really hard time being
alone um especially at night um and kind
of just being the the primary provider
on the days that I'm at work okay uh we
have four kids um and one of them has
some health problems and is just it's
kind of overwhelming for her to to be
the the primary the loan provider while
I'm gone um she also has a hard time
just missing or me missing family
activities and holidays every so often
um as well as just all the baggage that
comes with the types of calls that we
run like PTSD type stuff yeah so um I
have a family member that talked to me
um I grew up in a law enforcement
household and firefighter household and
um I had a family member tell me like
every day um
uh your dad goes to work I have to
wonder if he's going to come home that
that that fear is very very real that's
not what I'm hearing
here and so um because here's the deal
I'm I'm a YouTuber dude and I was a Dena
students before that and before that I
worked at Burger King all three of those
jobs I've had to miss some holiday stuff
all three of those jobs I've had to work
really late and miss a couple of this is
and that that's life so my fear is
you're going to quit this thing and this
imaginary life on the other side of this
is not going to be
real okay see what I'm saying so I would
not even Bankers keep Bankers hours now
that's right yeah and so I I would
strongly suggest youall go together at
the beginning okay and let's parse
through what this is because it sounds
like somebody who is growing
increasingly uncomfortable for any
number of reasons with the life that she
has and is getting to look out in the
crowd to see who can shoulder that with
her and you're the nearest guy okay does
that make sense it does and when you're
sitting at home and you've got one kid
that's sick and you got three other kids
that are burning the house down and
making as Dave pterodactyle noises
that's not a real good metaphor for a
firem oh my bad he has a
fireman um it's real easy another
example to create a story where it's the
job right yeah if she told me you know
what I love about this call though
Spencer is your wife um being so mature
that she's a recognizing that how much
you love what you do and B saying hey
before we make a big change let's get
some counsel it might be me and let's
look at I mean gosh that's so selfless
and mature on her part awesome that
gives me great hope that you guys can
find some ground that uh maybe you make
a few minor adjustments here or there to
uh meet some of those needs that she's
got um and then that'll help her meet
you the rest of the way um because I I
got to tell you the way she's
approaching this the way you described
her was very mature very cool I really
like her a lot oh me too I I definitely
married up she's a huge blessing in my
life well and but here's the deal I've
spent my life running around with you
guys and the fact that you immediately
when she talked to you you went to the
computer to see what other jobs are
available I know you did and that that
that makes you equally uh mature also
yeah you guys are willing to sacrifice
for each other you have the recipe for
an incredible relationship going forward
regardless of whether you stay in this
or not I think you'll find a way to stay
in it and she'll find a way to work with
part of her stuff and you'll find a way
I okay I can do this I can I can make
sure with my seniority level after 8
years on the for that um are in the
firehouse that I'm home on these dates I
can plan around that and um a minor
example it's not it's not exactly
parallel Spencer but when we were
starting all this stuff with that we now
call ramsy um my days were like 16 hour
days I missed everything Sharon I'll
tell you there's about two years she was
a single mom and uh cuz I worked all the
time getting this thing going I was
pulling this thing up by its hair right
and um we worked all the time
and so when we finally hit that same
wall a similar discussion we sat down
and we said okay I got to have some
non-negotiables so after that we never
booked a live event on a kid's birthday
we never took any speaking gigs ever on
around a holiday uh so I didn't miss any
Christmas I didn't miss any proms I
didn't miss any kids' birthdays after
that 2-year period and that was me
coming back towards her adjusting my
business you know to to be able to still
be a husband and a dad right and then in
the midst of that that gave her the that
gave her the strength to take up
whatever slack there still was which
there still was and she became a really
zero maintenance person from that point
forward and it's one of the reasons
we've been able to build this incredible
life so I just really think you're
willing to reach towards her with some
adjustments she's willing to reach
towards you y'all can reset a few things
here or there I really think you can
find this but because of the way you're
approaching it I think you're going to
be okay I think the key here with the
with the counselor is going to be really
pulling apart the specifics what are the
specifics can we hire somebody that
comes in from 400 P p.m. to 6 p.m. that
just helps with bedtimes and helps with
dinner help with clean up that's easy um
can we do something on Saturdays can we
make Christmas two days early every year
and that's just our fun thing we do
together as a family there's there's
ways around it uh if you got to right
yeah you you spend some of the money
you're earning to create a life that
becomes tolerable and sustainable that
you want yeah yeah that's what John's
saying and so that's help with the sick
child that's um you know uh a high
quality uh Nanny two days a week I don't
care what it is but on the days that
you're gone somebody's there helping
they're they're filling in you know and
uh that'd be worth it to stay doing what
you're doing that you love so much and
then she won't be worried about whether
you resent her because it's not her
she's trying to you know she's a single
mom when you're gone that's what she's
saying and um and that's the same thing
Sharon said and she was right you know
that's a very real thing so hey good
question man sound like good people I
think you're going to find the way
through that for sure um and again I
think it's largely because the way
you're approaching it she didn't stomp
in red-faced and scream you have to quit
your job I can't stand it and you didn't
say no I'm an entrepreneur or I'm a
fireman this is who I am so forget you
you know what you married and that's not
helpful either no no instead you you're
both saying I'm willing to give up a
piece of who I am to help you be who you
are right and that that's that's called
marriage I
think yeah and this is one of those
those weird things you when you see
somebody you talk to somebody like
Spencer and his and his amazing wife
that it feels like the wheels are
falling off and those of us who have
been through this and on other side of
that go oh no y your car's driving great
man you're just it's the terrain that's
rough it's not the car right and it
feels like oh think we're going to crash
you're not going to crash y y'all are
doing good you figure out your way out
through this yeah it's very smart to do
that because the career mental health
the money piece the wealth building
piece they're all woven together in a
way you cannot pull them apart it's
almost impossible to build wealth when
you have a crummy marriage it's almost
impossible to have a great marriage when
you're CR when you hate your job all the
time all these things work together and
so the Dr John deloney the Ramsey Show
the the Ken Coleman show these things
all the the stuff we talk about the
portions of your life they are woven
together in a very real
way that puts us hour of the Ramsey Show
in the
[Music]
books
oh
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Dr John deloney ramsy
personality is my co-host today open
phones atle 88
255 225 thank you for joining us Jesse
is in Atlanta starting off this hour hi
Jesse how are
you I'm wonderful thank you for taking
my call how are you better than I
deserve what's
up so my husband and I have um we read
The Total Money Makeover and we worked
diligently to get out of debt and
thankfully now we've paid off our Debs
and we own our home we are now in the
process thank you uh it was actually
through your book God did amazing things
through you um but so now we're in the
process of looking towards wealth
building and because of that I've been
looking at uh podcasts and different
videos on wealth building but I've been
noticing a recurring theme among a lot
of these very well-known people and it's
that they use these phrases everybody
has a prenup either the government makes
one or you make one yourself um and I
have always been someone that thinks
very negatively towards prenups my
husband and I when we were married
granted we were broke but we always felt
that the word divorce was out of the
question and that if you're even
considering a prenup then you're opening
yourself up to the possibility of a
divorce so I wanted your opinion as a
Christian as somebody who is wealthy
what is your uh perspective on prenups
and especially in the in the Christian
room so it's more in theory because it
obviously doesn't apply to you
all correct but to I guess the reason
that I'm asking it is because I it kind
of helps me in Discerning are these
people that I should get advice from
like Welling is this people that I
should be listening to well I I don't
know who you're listening to and don't
tell me but um uh typically what happens
in something like that is a financial
person is uh the financial people and uh
legal people both uh are the world's
worst and I I had to break myself of
this when I started doing this several
years ago are the world's worst at
looking at life through only one
lens okay you're asking a question
through a relational lens a spiritual
lens and a wealth building and legal
lens they're only looking at it for
wealth
protection if if you could live a life
which you can't that wealth protection
was
separated from your relationships and
was separated from your spiritual walk
you can't but if you could then a prenup
would be a slam dunk and in their minds
therefore a prenup is a SL slam dunk
because they only see it through that
lens does that make sense yes so I
wouldn't necessarily discredit them uh
for all of their advice as somehow being
a heresy or something like that I would
just say whoever you're listening to is
only looking at the advice they're
giving through a singular lens our
approach is we believe that personal
finance is 80% behavior and we've proven
that it's not about math and it's not
about that stuff so uh our approach is
is that the prenup actually could end up
uh stunting your growth because you're
not all in on working
together so when I first started this
show when I first started this show I
was 100% never get a prenup under any
circumstances don't get married if you
love your stuff more than you love her
period just don't do it that's how I
started now having done this a long time
I have one caveat that I've added about
a decade ago to this and that is if two
people are getting married one of them
has extreme wealth there's an extreme
difference like I had one guy um who was
marrying a lady who had $ 10 million and
he didn't have two
nickels okay I suggested a prenup to
them uh to keep their relationship pure
about relationship and not about money
and the bigger reason I suggested to
them is my now experience 30 years later
has been the prenup in that case is not
really for that couple it's for all the
weirdos in their
families because all of the sudden crazy
mother-in-law swoops in from the other
side once the $10 million Golden Goose
shows up and you got to look at then you
got a little piece of paper and you look
at her and go sorry ma got a prenup
can't do
nothing and so it gives them a defense
mechanism against crazy in their family
cuz one thing we know about wealth is it
magnifies everything and that includes
crazy so when you got crazy members in
your family and you marry $10 million
dad gum the crazy comes out you know so
in that case I did recommend a prenup in
extreme differences but from 99% of the
people just regular folk getting married
and you know I had one lady call me up
one time and said her boyfriend had a
1968 frame up restoration Mustang and he
wanted a
prenup and you know my answer to that is
don't marry this bozo he loves his car
more than
you you know that's not that's the
that's the answer to that and that's not
a you know that might not jive with
these other guys podcast or whoever it
is you're listening to but um most of
the time I agree with where you're
coming from Jesse and that is the prenup
is simply planning the divorce in
advance oh oh 52% of the marriages end
in divorce no they don't no they don't
not when you take out people with
four-year degrees not when you take out
people who regularly attend a house of
worship not when you take out people who
the parents on neither side were
divorced when you take those statistics
out almost 90% of the people make their
marriage
work oh and you're you're older than 22
years old and you didn't have a baby
before marriage you can take these
things out boom boom boom boom boom
success rate of marriage goes way up you
make $50,000 a year or more household
income you didn't have a baby before
marriage you didn't get married in high
school you know all these kind you take
all that crap out you got about a 90%
survival rate of marriages so that 52%
figure includes a whole bunch of other
crap going on of people who weren't
going to make it anyway so you can't use
52% of marriages and a divorce because
they really don't Jesse I'm gonna ask
Dave a question on your behalf is that
cool yes um so Dave let me throw a
caveat in here tell me what you think
about
this um a 55-year-old who's done pretty
well not extreme wealth um spouse passes
away and a Mary's a 57y old who's done
pretty well spouse passes away both have
kids both have cousins does it make
sense in that situation again to protect
from family and if you if you wanted to
but you've just got to be very careful
because it's a you you're entering
you're you're trying to say this stuff
the distribution of this stuff is more
important than this
relationship and man that's dangerous
and so if you don't have an ex basically
if you don't have an exit ramp we got to
figure this out yeah we got to figure it
out yeah a good I mean if you don't
trust her to leave your Bible to your
son from the first marriage whose mom
died then don't marry her then don't
marry her right you know that's what I'm
saying and so there's a whole whole
thing that goes into play here but yeah
by and large I'm anti- preup that would
take because I believe you're planning
your divorce believe you're asking for
trouble and you know it's it's cheapens
the whole Affair and puts a dollar
figure to it and I just I'm not doing
that now if there's an extreme
difference like I said there's a few
times it's okay you talk about it but
it's it's a dangerous thing thanks for
the question it's a good
[Music]
one
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Lee is in Cleveland Ohio hi
Lee how are
you hi I'm good how are you better than
I deserve what's
up um quick question uh my parents they
are entering their 70s and um I swear
that is the important part um they
called a family meeting with me and my
sisters as three of us girls and they
wanted to know what our thoughts were on
how they leave their
basically Financial State behind whether
it be a will or a trust and we're not
one we didn't expect them to even want
our advice because you know it's their
um but now that they're asking not
really sure what direction to go they
had mentioned a will an estate it just
it's a
lot do they have a lot of
money um yeah the number they said yeah
yeah it's well it's a lot to us what's a
lot how much um just south of five
million that's a lot that's a very cool
that's a lot for the three girls so you
guys are going to get over a million a
piece when they both die and just trying
to plan that out yeah okay they do not
have any federal estate tax what state
are they
in Ohio okay you need to find out what
the probate tax is in Ohio but I suspect
like it is in Most states that the best
thing they can do is a simple
will it's um typically uh what'll happen
in a situation like that would be what
we call a mirror image will where they
do they both do the exact same will
except the names are changed so his will
would say everything goes to
her unless we die together and then
everything goes to the girls three ways
okay and her will would say exactly the
same thing everything goes to husband
unless we die together and then
everything goes to the girls three ways
okay it's not it's not expensive because
it's cut and paste right you do one will
and cut and paste the thing mirror image
will there's no uh again there's no
federal estate tax on an estate of $5
million the probate is um a tax to run
it through the probate and you'd have to
find out what it is in Ohio um but I
would not go to the expense of a trust a
trust is typically going to run you $3
to $5,000 to have an attorney do it and
um you don't need it there's no need for
it well that that was the other question
there in inent with um when they
mentioned a trust is to make sure that
it is protected so like all three of us
girls are married um we're all in our
30s and they just want to make it so
it's ours and obviously none of us hope
or plan for divorce but to make sure
it's protected um you know for longevity
sake and that well if you have the use
of the money it's going into your name
it's not protected and so if it's
sitting over in a trust and you can't
touch it then it's protected but that's
silly you need to have the use of
it well they would want us to if it were
a trust they would want us to all be um
all three of us I I wouldn't do that
managers I wouldn't do that yeah please
don't do that like live off interest I
guess yeah now the other thing you can
check on and again the law will change
from state to state and I'm not an
attorney so two things you need to look
at you need to learn about is find out
what the probate tax in Ohio is okay and
in most Most states and I think this is
true in Ohio but you need to verify it
if you were left a million half dollars
from your parents and three years later
you went through a divorce the judge
would award that money to
you really in most
States now not a it's the you know it's
a it came from your side of the family
it doesn't he doesn't automatically get
it now uh you know if a period of 50
years years went by then there may be a
different thing okay before you got
divorced but um but you know a few years
out you know five or 10 years something
like that in Most states you're going
the judge is going to cover that and
something that came from you know
somewhere else it's obviously was your
money it'd be like if you married
someone without a prenup we were talking
about that a minute ago and you brought
money into the marriage and then you get
a divorce shortly thereafter you're
going to take that money out of the
marriage in most States now some states
have different common law stuff but and
so I'd want to learn about that to be
100% sure but by and large I really
wouldn't over complicate this for a
million and a half
dollars sure okay that makes sense I
would keep my life pretty clean and
pretty simple um but but learn about it
and so you can address their concerns
and by the way that also means they
probably ought to talk to an estate
planning attorney or two they they have
lawyers and so they were kind of running
through the options and were running us
through the options by way of the
lawyers just that were planning their
estate so they they have lawyers that
well they could address that those two
issues then that I'm talking about
probate tax and whether or not you're
protected in the event of a divorce
without a trust I TR trust unless you've
got a you know $100 million two $20
million $50 million it's a lot it's so
cumbersome to deal with and there's some
estate planning reason or estate tax
reasons to do that when you get up above
20 million right now but uh but prior to
that I would just keep my life as simple
as I could if I were you gosh yeah and
I'd be weary of an attorney trying to
Pro push uh uh Trust on you just because
they're going to make an extra $5,000
yeah and some of the people in the
estate planning world do that they're
they're they're they oh you need a trust
to
avoid no everybody doesn't need a trust
you really don't um you you really
really don't need one that often so hey
good question thank you for joining us
Michelle is in Dayton Ohio hi Michelle
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up um to
make a long story short um I lost my mom
to about two years ago to co um her and
I lived together um my whole life but
the last 12 years we roomed together um
because her and my dad separated um so I
honestly feel like the last the first
year I was numb the last year I've just
kind of been living in survival mode um
and long story short I did stupid about
a month ago and um went out and traded
in my car for a new one and I realized
pretty quick it was dumb um I was kind
of stressed out and I was going through
a box of my mom's stuff and on top of it
was a book that I had never seen before
it was Rachel Cruz's know yourself know
your money and I started reading that it
kind of turned me on to your guys' show
again my mom listened to you guys here
and there um but I guess what I'm where
I'm at right now is I I need to get out
from underneath this car but I'm not
really sure what to do um you know I
feel like I need to sell it I I I don't
have anything but student loans and and
the car payment but um it's pretty much
top my budget out um and I'm like what
if something happens in my rent raises
or you know crazy stuff like that stuff
I should have thought about before I did
it but I guess where I'm at is I just
don't know how to you know what steps to
take to get out from underneath this car
I know obviously selling it is probably
the best bet but I'm pretty sure soon as
you drive it off the lot I'm going to
owe more than what it's worth um and so
I'm just trying to get some advice on
what to do and where to start um without
what were you driving
before uh I had a car I had a 2020 Kia
Sportage I traded it in for a new one
okay how much did they give you for the
Kia I was underwater on that about a
th000 bucks so I put 2500 down with what
they gave me I ended up putting about
1,500 down okay um on the car okay yeah
so I the car is $30,000 note um 31,000
actually and you make what I'm just got
a new job um working for the government
so I'm making about 50,000 a year yeah
okay you're you're right you do need to
sell it oh man what you been through
kiddo I'm sorry um that big a big time
Big Time grieving and stress purchase
wasn't it yeah yeah yeah it was just I
don't I just said I've had a temporary
moment of insanity but at the same time
it's kind of fueled this like I would
how long you had the car in the face uh
about a month go back and talk to the
dealer and see if you can how big a
check you got a right to get out of
it okay that's first thing if it's if
the check sounds unreasonable check what
the car will sell for and you're going
to have to cover the difference the hole
that you're in you're right you're
upside down again and you're going to
have to go buy something super cheap
that you can pay cash for and scrape
together the money to cover the
difference to get out of this thing but
you're right you need to undo this and
the sooner you undo it the better
because every day you drive it it's
going down in value even more this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host he's also the author of the
number one bestselling book building a
nonanxious life it's our latest number
one bestseller here at Ramsey and you
ought to be able to check it out in the
lobby of ramsy solutions hanging out
with us on the stage Anthony from
Lancaster Pennsylvania hi Anthony how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve how can we help you today sir
just have a question how do I get my
19-year-old stepdaughter to follow the
Ramsay plan and pay for college Cash
when she says she'll let her future self
worry about the debt your 19-year-old
stepdaughter your wife's daughter yes
okay how long you'all been married uh 10
and a half years okay so you knew her
when she was nine yes and she said
that's a problem for future me it's kind
of awesome
yeah
wow um can I just take a guess here that
um the other parent is fully on take out
every loan and go get them maybe okay
yeah okay so Dad her dad is saying
probably yeah future self um so
uh well I the thing the couple things I
that pop into my head and John you're
probably mean to address this a lot more
than me I'm just thinking like a dad
um unless there's a fractured
relationship your wife is going to have
a better chance of having this
conversation than you because you're by
definition the stepdad uh unless you're
the only hero in this whole story uh
with this kid that you've got more
credibility than her actual two parents
you know um it'd be nice if she'd listen
to your wisdom but you're probably man
out uh and and so what we've got to do
is get somebody in front of her that
she'll listen to so that's first what
I'm looking for is who who's she most
likely to hear from and then whoever
that is I'm going to school them uh just
as a dad this is Dave the dad you know
one of the things one of the hardest
times for me in parenting was when my
kids grew up and I couldn't tell them
what to do
anymore it's pissed me off cuz it was a
lot easier when I could just tell them
what to do and it's it's and now they're
30 and 40 years old and I still can't
tell them what to do it's just awful I
can't even tell them what to do with the
grandkids it's awful so um I've had to
learn to not use my dad
voice my only shot at dealing with a
quote grown-up in this case a
19-year-old is to speak to them as if
they were someone else's kid and I was
trying to persuade them like if one of
my buddy's kid was going to do this I
would sit down and I would use a
different voice than my dad's voice um
and I'd say you know I love you and let
me walk you through because I love you
why I think this is stupid and why I
think it's stupid for you it doesn't
affect me you get to do whatever you
want to do but one definition of
maturity honey is learning to delay
pleasure and this little future self
thing you've said is an indication
you're acting like you're four and
that's what I would tell one of my
friends kids but um as if they were a
caller on this show you know but it's
not me using my dad voice cuz the
instant she hears anything other than
persuasion as a technique she's going to
click off and move on even if she she
physically sitting there she quit
listening yeah I I I I think exactly
right I think it's important for you two
you and your wife to say here's what our
rules and boundaries are for our money
and how we're going to support or not
support and then walk your like he said
I think you have that conversation I
have found it really helpful when
parents own up to some things they have
done when they put things off to future
self and it humanizes you a little bit
and it's part of the persuasion you're
having an adult to adult conversation
even though she's 19 and you know she's
every bit a child is as she was when she
was 16
um I okay I did this one time and that
may not work but at least you become
more credible instead of just this
pointing finger and saying you're going
to I bought a car I couldn't afford and
I thought future self would worry about
it right and I didn't sleep a lot and it
tore me up and I got messed up my credit
and it set me back and it's one of the
financial decisions I made that held me
back and I just don't want that pain for
you cuz I love you you know that kind of
thing there's also going to be a strange
thing that happens um and you have
probably dealt with it her whole life is
if she has one parent saying I think you
should do
this then there's a loyalty thing that
gets really dicey and really weird and
so sometimes the greatest gift you can
say is I think you're making a mistake I
don't think this is the right move I
love you and I'm gonna be here when you
get back and I've got a plan for you to
pay all this mess off um I don't think
it's the right thing but there's that
weird loyalty thing that they feel like
if they're doing something even if it's
better for them and they know it that
they're being disloyal and somehow
unloving to the other
parent like this Situation's messy it's
just messy that's why it's important for
y'all too to get your boundaries
straight we're going to pay for your
first semester at college but it's going
to come this or this or we can put this
money on the table but you can't borrow
a dime if you borrow a dime you're op
you are opting out of this money
whatever I'm not I've got $20,000 to put
towards your college but it's not there
if you're doing this if you take out a
loan you're opting out of my money and
because I'm not going to support you in
doing something that's harmful to you I
love you too much I'm not going to buy
your drugs if you're a heroin addict and
I'm not going to participate in
something I think is a mistake and
harmful to you not because I'm greedy
and not because the money's yours but
it's not yours to do harm with because I
love you too much and this you need to
hear this B if you're participating if
you're not participating in the in the
college education at all then you're
simply trying to persuade right and I
like putting the onus on them because
what a good 19-year-old will do is when
you say I'm not going to put I'm not
giving you any of this college money if
you um if you take out a loan then man
you're the bad guy you're withholding
you don't want me to get educated you
don't love me but when you say hey
19-year-old you're opting out of this
money it's right here the terms of this
money are X Y and Z you're opting out
you're a grownup you get to do that a
similar thing would be in our case with
our kids when they were in school if
they were going to misbehave in other
ways while at school and they weren't
going to make grades while at school
they're opting out I'm not I'm not going
to pay for I'm not playing for you to go
pay play beer pong you're you're I'm
playing for you to go get an education
and this is not your time to party and
Daddy pays for it screw that you know
and so we had these conversations early
and often as I sent checks into the
thing but this is this this money is
contingent my love is not contingent but
this stream of money coming at your
college experience is contingent and
they get to decide well that money keeps
coming Yeah by their behavior yeah so
you're opting in you're opting out if
you guys are participating that's the
thing on that but I I think the thing is
this it's just a mistake and we've got
we got you know she say 44 million
people in America that'll tell her it's
a mistake they got student loans out
there yingyang and they can't breathe
and they're waiting on the president to
mysteriously make it go away and he's
not he can't and he won't um and so it's
you know it's a mistake and when you
anytime you say the future me that just
means I want to buy something now and
I'm being a four-year-old on the cereal
AIS having a fit because I want Froot
Loops and so it's a cute saying though I
like her I like her angle it's kind of
it's kind of funny but uh I'll let the
future me deal with that that's kind of
funny she's got she's got Moxy but um we
so we threw a lot at you what do you
think you're right we had x amount of
money that we had that we said we would
give if she stayed at home she could
have used that for four years but she
decided to dorm and all that's being
used the first year and we said we're
not going to co-sign for any loans yeah
okay so she used up the money even
though she went a direction you said not
to do and now it's even gone further and
we're not co-signing the loans so now
she's going to have to be out of school
yeah that's sad or she'll have to go to
a local community college and go for
free depending on what state yall live
in right right heaven forbid yeah um I
think that's a great option for families
yeah great option but you know yeah you
you guys yeah so you're F we're further
into this than I realized I don't know
why I thought a 19-year-old wouldn't
already in school I was thinking this I
thought we cut it ahead of time no I
mean this is a beautiful opportunity for
you to show here's what the account was
there's no dollars left it's empty now
yeah you used it and I I kind made a
mistake allowing you to do that and I'm
not going to make another one by signing
for you for sure and if you need a
co-signer you're up a creek so um wow
but she probably doesn't need a co-
Center she's probably just going to keep
rocking most depends on what school is
it expensive private school no it's a
public school public school well they're
all expensive now so yeah not cheap but
all right best of luck to you man
appreciate your question I I wish I had
a magic wand to make that go away that's
some thoughts for you and you parents
out there you know one guy called up and
said my daughter told me he she's going
to the school and I said see that's
where it ended at the Ramsay cuz we did
the telling they didn't do the telling
like someone calls and says my
11-year-old's addicted to their iPad I
said no they're
not you keep handing it to him you won't
take it away cuz you have no spine this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Proverbs 17:17
a friend loves at all times and a
brother is born for a time of adversity
Mother Teresa says some people come into
your life as a blessing other people
come into your life as
lessons there's mentors and there's
anti- mentors I think I'm the blessing
for you Dave that's it that's it I knew
it when I got up this morning I said
that's it John Dr John it's my blessing
he's a blessing bless me you are my
adversity I love it well hey everybody's
got to have a gift Danielle is in new
lden Connecticut hi Danielle how are you
I'm well how are you better than I
deserve what's
up um so I'm kind of in a place in my
marriage where I'm trying to figure out
um if I should be coming or going um we
had uh twins two years ago
and um I think that there was just um a
lot of unrealistic
expectations um of having kids together
um for from him to me and um he was just
very disconnected from them the first
year and a half so he started connecting
with them through counseling and it's
almost like you're too late I guess it's
there's no there's no um I don't have
those feelings anymore and it's like the
more suggestions counseling comes up
with um the more it's almost like cringy
like I'm like I don't I don't want to do
that you know maybe if you did this that
and the other you know made the 18
bottles you know in the first year I
would have gladly you know accepted to
want to go on a date or XYZ but I'm just
I so are you are you are you leaving
your
marriage I'm pretty close to it
yeah and what I've got from this call is
um your husband did not do a good job
during the first year year and a half of
yeah having twins dropped in the house
and because of that um he sounds like he
is trying to work on it and fix things
and you're saying nope your punishment
for those first 18 months is I'm
out in a sense yeah it sounds like
you're out of the marriage and this has
become a great exit strategy for you a
story that allows you a pass in your
mind to
leave in a sense
yeah okay so what's your
question um I guess I'm not trying to
just leave like I said it's
I mean sounds like that's exactly what
you're
doing I understand that but what I'm
just trying to advise is what else can I
do at this point if
I I don't know we're trying with
marriage counseling I see the connection
now he's building with our
kids I just don't know how to keep
trying
I I think you know how to keep trying I
don't think you want
to yeah here's the deal y'all got to
build something completely
new and he sounds like he is really
trying to build something new and you're
just standing there at the in the rubble
and you don't want to pick up a hammer
and you're waiting for that hammer to
feel
right it's never going to feel right The
Feelings Will Follow the action and so
either you decide I'm going to go all
in we're going to figure this thing out
or I'm going to stop suffocating
everybody in the house with I don't know
I'm just waiting for like you see what
I'm
saying no I understand what you're
saying I think you've got to fight for
your marriage in the same way he seems
to be fighting for your
marriage what am I
missing uh there's a lot more pieces to
it but for this short synopsis
um like I said I just got used to doing
everything on my own and so now that
someone's now coming around trying to
help it's
just it feels like it's a it's a ploy
like how long is this going to last
because it's that's kind of what
happened before it's just I'll do this
for a little bit and then it
stops your are your parents
divorced um yes how old were you when
your dad
left um maybe 10
m I think you're still pissed at
him uh biolog no
uh I no hard feelings towards any of my
parents
bull okay
you I don't I ask me your question
because I really don't know I I don't
know how I can help what what you're
telling me is it's a very
syrupy feelings like I just don't feel
like now if you came back and said no
the dude was abusive dude cheated on me
a lot and he's trying to weasel his way
back in that's a whole different
conversation but what and I know we have
very compressed time but what you're
telling me right now is I had to do a
lot of work the first 18 months because
he was off working when I had twins and
I it killed me
and now I got used to doing things alone
and I don't want his help
anymore and so I'm just going to divorce
him that's what that's what I'm hearing
I can't be right no that's it um well we
both work um so it's not just that he's
working we both were working during this
it just he just mentally disconnected
from helping me raise our two kids even
though he has other two kids so I got
you but listen to me that was yesterday
we're here today okay so let's make a
choice about
today if you're going to leave your
marriage because your husband is trying
to make things right and learn a new way
of helping and admittedly he sucked the
first 18 months and he's trying his best
and you're like no I'd rather do it
myself you have to own that
decision
MH if you're going to leave him over
that then you've got to own that
decision yeah I don't know I don't I
feel like I'm missing
something but I'll say this if if you're
trying to heal a marriage any level of
it being
broken the same as if you're trying to
get in shape the same as if you're
trying to get out of debt if you wait
for it to feel right you're never going
to do
it you have to just take wild action in
the direction of the thing you want to
be different whether that's losing
weight whether that's getting out of
debt whether that's saying I'm GNA fight
to the death for this freaking marriage
and you suck the last two years and
we're going to make this right I'm in
yeah and if absent of that it's it's
just going to be this ah it doesn't feel
good and it doesn't and by the way if
you look around at our culture we're a
feeling to death
culture we all wait for everything to
feel the right there is not it's not
going to get that way what you're going
to do is you're going to run like wild
in the direction of what you want which
is an amazing marriage and some help
around the house and two awesome kids
with two great parents and then you're
going to wake up one day and realize
this feels really
awesome
yeah but that choice is yours I can't
make that for you yeah no I know I
appreciate
it yeah feel like I'm missing something
Dave
uh I don't know I don't know we're
missing I don't
know I've got an opinion but it's harsh
so I'll just keep it to myself
yeah I would like America to see that
Dave Ramsey is maturing getting
older I think this is important step in
this Show's
Evolution well I'm and I'm I I don't
want to sit beside a PhD in counseling
and have counseling ideas it's a bad
idea no bring it bring it it's a bad
idea I think she's still pissed at her
dad I'm just being pop psychologist
though and and so the first time her
husband screwed up she transferred it I
just moved it over yeah she's moved it
over to him and so this is this is her
way of hitting back at her dad but I'm
I'm really reaching here yeah is that is
that possible I I think your body puts a
pin in that pain and you wait for it and
wait for it and goes there it is there
it is somebody's not doing what they're
supposed to do all right I'm out
somebody's not doing what they're
supposed to do y I'm not going to yeah
your body throws that wall up and it's
game over yeah I could be wrong I I mean
I'm just I'm just a novice at this stuff
I get to sit next to you though so
there's that that puts us hour the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
uh with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus
[Music]
a